hi there today I'm gonna talk a bit
about Spanish when was the US when I
start this as I say good afternoon good
morning or good day um porque and porque
apparently this causes some
consternation for Spanish learners so I
thought I would give you my perspective
on this as a learner of Spanish and at
least I was a learner of Spanish now I
am enjoying what I'm able to do in
Spanish it's not perfect of course the
first thing is that in any issue in
language I always say that don't rely
too much on the explanations you can
easily Google for K and porque and
you'll find lots of explanations
explanations can be a little bit sort of
how would I put it you have the feeling
when you read the explanation that
you're learning something and
understanding something but very often
half hour later you forgotten what was
there so the explanation kind of gives
you a sense but it's only one small part
of starting to master a particular
pattern in the language simply put if
you hear
porque porque in Spanish can mean Y okay
it can mean because poor kid it can even
mean know the reason why you know and I
know there's he told me why so I'm not
asking the question but he told me the
reason why in which case so those are
the collet those are the three most
common all right when you hear porque
you're not aware necessarily of the fact
that in some cases it has an accent in
some cases it's written as two words of
course when you are reading you should
pay a lot of attention to how that
porque is written and of course when you
go to write in Spanish if you have to
then you really got to think about how
you should write now since we mostly
write on computers these days you can
always look it up and every time you
look it up and you read the explanation
you can retain the explanation for long
enough to get it right while you're
writing and that'll eventually help you
to learn it but very simply stated
porque y por que as the question
porque is in two words and the K has an
accent on okay wanna so for K Y and the
answer is because part K alright and so
that's pretty straightforward so when
you're speaking as long as you realize
that Y it because it's essentially when
you're hearing it the same word you're
happy same when you're going to use it
for cape okay why because same word no
problem it's only when you are having to
write in the language that you have to
be a little more careful and that's why
when you read in the language you should
pay attention to which one it is
all right now what can help what helps
me and any of these issues is my
knowledge of other languages all right
so for example in French they porque as
in why is parsec oh so it's actually a
different word
whereas scoonie the because a pasture
car is a different word whereas the four
K as in why is poop quoi alright except
the French have it is one word but it
does it's an example of how these things
can help you it's like you know often
with my genders in in French if you say
we're like look vocabulary vocabulary
ends in E which is often feminine but if
I think of my Spanish L vocabulary oh
that helps me remember that look it's a
male vocabulary
it's the same with como and como in
Spanish if you say a question like coma
means how como has an accent on your
butt como also means as commercially
fair as it is as we say okay so there
again in French you can refer to Como as
the question is come on in French
whereas como as in como se if they come
you know como como me preface it seems
to me is like [ __ ] comm e in French you
know even the English can help you say
if you're looking at that porque as in a
question
for what
because k can mean what but if it's the
because it's for that because k is also
that so it does make sense and i find
sometimes these cross language
references english to spanish it's an
easier way of remembering how these
words are used sometimes then the
explanation but everyone has to find
their own way of making these things
natural so the explanation including the
explanation that i just gave you is just
a little bit of a nudge in the direction
of getting used to these things but it
is it's only through lots of listening
and reading lots of paying attention
underlining when you're reading saving
phrases a link if you're on link in
other words forcing your brain to pay
attention and gradually then these
things become a habit so there shouldn't
be any difficulty with poor camp okay
other than and in other words i find
myself in the situation of well first of
all you know i don't pay much attention
to it because my needs in spanish are
simply listening already and if scuse me
listening reading and speaking I don't
write much in Spanish so I don't have to
think about whether there's one word two
word accent about accent so I don't even
bother with it so in a way it's
sometimes difficult for me to explain I
get a bit confused as I I'm explaining
it but you know for those of you who
need to write exams recognize the fact
that every time you look it up on Google
while you're writing every time you pay
attention to it you're gradually in
graining these habits and that's the
only way you're gonna get it right more
often than not over time although you'll
occasionally get it wrong so I hope
that's useful let me know what you think
and and if this kind of thing is useful
I can have more videos on specific
aspects of different languages that seem
to cause people difficulty so there you
have it thanks for listening bye for now
[Music]